this logo looks like a goth chicks
tattoo 53 seconds of logos a talking
head scene with a character explaining
their backstory as narrations annoying
cousin my parents if I were defending
them which I'm not had said back in the
day that he had an impatient eye they
didn't like him not too many parents in
the world who would like a substitute
teacher putting the moves on their
teenage daughter also Loretta still
doesn't seem to understand why this
would be a problem despite now being a
parent way my parents looked me up on
the Internet asked to meet their
grandchildren so you decide to send your
kids off to meet your parents and you
don't show them any pictures or have a
quick chat on the phone they're good
people good people that you've hated so
much you haven't spoken to them in 15
years I'm on the text with two separate
girls I explained on the text yes please
do
I maybe only but I mean that's not a
thing your phones won't work all the way
out there you'll be home Saturday quick
Graham in some expositional sentences
before the mother leaves also how does
she know the phones won't work she
hadn't been there in 15 years technology
has come a long way lady
you know I used to be a pretty good at
this ticket collector is unbelievably
chummy it's almost like he's here to
drop a not-so-subtle hint about the
twist at the end of the movie I'm
chilling begin I'm feeling again I'm
like Iron Man and Batman I'm a Hugo yeah
I have no problem if this kid dies
already also this movie dedicates too
much time to this kid rapping I looked
away for a second and thought my
computer decided to change damn a DB
raps YouTube channel to people we find
out later are crazy and can't remember
anything so I'm gonna make this
appointment to pick up the kids at the
right place and time she's a good cook
how could she know this the food in that
container is boolean consumed and she
just got here this is the perfect
cinematic image to open the documentary
so are we just watching all the wrong
footage or did she want her documentary
to be extremely meta wait wait don't
touch it
just let it organically swing this goes
on for some time let it organically
swing the perfect cinematic image to
open the documentary includes her
brother weirdly smiling behind the swing
there's the clock that she told us about
their mom explained the clock in great
detail but never got around to
describing what her parents look like
why are you paying so low I rap okay two
things his pants are on normally and I
rap is not a suitable excuse for low
pants I know plenty of people that wear
their pants low and don't worry the
girls
they like me this goes on for sometime
you remind me of a pineapple upside-down
cake
ho I guess in freestyle rap you don't
actually have to rap about the topic you
just have to say it at the end also ho
why would you drop a ho bomb around his
grandparents by the way there's mold in
the basement we don't want you guys to
get sick it's good these kids know
nothing about mold because if they did
they would know mold travels with the
flow of air which would screw them up
regardless of where they are so Beca
doesn't find it odd that there aren't
any pictures of Nana and pop-pop around
the house pretty sure Nana and pop-pop
are not paying for broadband Internet
making it impossible for them to have a
perfect HD Skype call with mom I guess
they're trying to get their money's
worth for Catherine Hong oh my sales
associates gonna be on the world's
largest cruise ship
I bet literally thousands of all Mart
associates have been on cruise ships
this is the first camera but mom found
in the damaged goods bin movie narrowly
avoids me sending them for this
fifteen-year-old daughter of a Walmart
sales associate owning this camera but
I'm gonna do it anyway kid does a sponge
bob impression what kid does sit-ups and
flannel at their grandparents house read
a book or jack off in the bathroom or
something I've decided to use female pop
singers names instead of cursing from
now on this seems sexist somehow becca
t-diamond stylus every adult humours
that kid to an insane degree even the
insane people this haircut is known as
the child actor I'm now worried that I'm
going to be forced to share a jail cell
with Jared Fogle this is another
similarity between the movie and a Royal
Caribbean cruise well it appears the
Amityville Horror obsession with
chopping firewood invests all horror
movie villains made me manufactured
swoopy sound to create a jump-scare ish
because the filmmakers remember they
were actually trying to make a horror
movie how is he able to scoot this fast
and not hit his head on anything this
doesn't seem possible
Nana saw the ring for a feeble woman
then it has a pretty good crab crawl I
used to be an actor back in my day the
only reason I can gather for Bob Costas
over here to harass this girl about his
previous acting experience is that this
is some kind of hint Nana and pop-pop
are acting like their grandparents and
that makes me sad also he in the Amtrak
guy both leave out the most important
part of that line if the tale told by an
idiot full of sound and fury signifying
nothing
which basically sums up the movie tell
them there's a lot of excitement down at
the hospital and I can't wait to tell
him I know they love gossip and buy
excitement he means that two of the
patients are missing because that sounds
more like a legit problem than
excitement
smells like ass in here shouldn't he be
able to correctly identify the smell of
human feces I mean we saw him go in the
bathroom on the train
exactly and all signs were pointing to
this being a filled pile of diapers
smells like ass there were flies buzzing
over this mysterious pile and you saw
what looks like depends you had that
coming kid he hides his accidents in the
shed and then I think he burns them out
in the field he's such a physical man he
gets ashamed this is the most depressing
horror film I've ever seen this was
young Loretta's high school wait why
aren't these kids in school there's no
Thanksgiving or Christmas decorations
anywhere so it's not like it's taking
place over a holiday break did their mom
just yank them out of school for a week
to visit total strangers so she could
hop on a boat and her hot boyfriend I
see why there was a rift in the family
over Loretta should be decision making
an escaped mental patient beats a man in
the middle of town in broad daylight
totally gets away with it
maybe the hospital didn't refer to
dangerous people escaping their care as
excitement and gossip cops could be on a
lookout for this exact kind of thing
also did they just throw that camera in
a puddle not only can it collect footage
all day but it's also waterproof good
find mom this movie is a lot like
Paranormal Activity only with way more
naked grandma's it's called Sun guarding
it's called sundowning then why is 9:30
the magic time and not like 6:00 or
whenever the Sun sets in the winter up
north if you're gonna murder a couple
people and take over their lives it's
pretty important that you pick people
who wear the same size clothes I spill
some biscuit batter on it I tried to
clean it with cleaner Nana isn't great
at making her vandalism look like an
accident I downloaded the definition of
sundowning all right she downloaded
something she could have just looked up
it's got to do with neurological
reactions to sunshine and moonlight I
did my own reading on sundowning and got
different results that are mostly
related to Alzheimer's but then again I
didn't download anything just come to
accept they're old people and things
won't be as weird that's racist so weird
I can't see you I looked it up Wi-Fi to
access Skype on a Royal Caribbean cruise
is $25 a day this Walmart associate is
totally wasting our money
I knew we're gonna have this call your
old Tyler there's a huge difference
between regular elderly forgetfulness
and a shed full of dirty diapers also
her parents aren't that old they're in
their early 70s and active and lucid
enough to volunteer
I can hear the Cougars clapping and
later guys I'm gonna have unprotected
sex with that dude who isn't your dad
his penis is huge anyway and see you
later
is Nana coming on to me Nana can I ask
you about mom for the first time since I
got here would you mind getting inside
the oven to clean it I'm too big Nana
was just standing next to Becca
and they are definitely the same size so
this is just an odd request to build
tension that leads nowhere all the way
in how deep is this oven also are we
supposed to think the grandma is a witch
Hansel and Gretel style where did you
first meet papa in a car I guess next
question isn't could you be a little
more specific yeah Becca is acting brie
channel about what could possibly be a
seizure the camera just toggle focus
even though no one is operating it maybe
it's the ghost that this movie isn't
about hope things don't get weirder my
limit I hope you don't rap again because
I'm at my limit cue Nana no but dad is
hilarious that's funny he set the funny
car to the fat lady on the boardwalk he
sounds exactly as hilarious as a
uniquely annoying 13 year old boy can't
imagine why Nana and pop-pop hated this
guy your sweaters inside out did you
know that layer in the middle of the
fucking Road actually shoes anything
that has my dad in it so I guess she
doesn't realize that her dad is in the
footage playing behind her making the
current footage unusable Nana and
pop-pop get conveniently leaving right
as people stop by even though I'm happy
this woman isn't reciting Macbeth right
now it's weird that she's ignoring the
camera altogether I hear all that
scuttlebutt down at Maple Shade high I
don't think so
so there was no follow-up on the
scuttlebutt what a normal conversation
be this lady explaining to the kid about
the escapees and then she and her
brother running away she's laughing he's
just watching TV
wouldn't Becca know at this point that
they don't have a TV I feel like the
first thing teenagers would do upon
their arrival is find the TV especially
if their phones don't work I have a deep
dark case
they're like the Blue Meanies but racist
they're just cleaning it that's what I
always say when someone walks in on me
while I'm home he's holding a gun we
needed a reminder that this kid is a
germaphobe because we are all so bored
we forgot this is M night Shyamalan s
attempt to break into the Paranormal
Activity genre of horror but he forgets
to add any paranormal or any activity
okay that's a pretty good jump scare but
let me ask this question we find out
there's nothing supernatural going on so
how does a crazy old lady in a trance
know the camera is there in the dark
forms a plan to jump scared out of
anybody who watches the footage I mean
you she didn't see that camera and after
that she was no longer pissed at the
camera and politely put it back where
she found it also why didn't we see the
kids reactions to the jump scare isn't
that the important thing here would not
be entertaining to watch hey I have a
great idea for a show called kids react
we're ending this trip tonight better
idea and this trip right we know yeah
he's run around the factory at night
only I saw it started telling people
about it me I didn't believe me had
yellow eyes this is the scary movie M
night should have ate by the way while
we're sitting here watching footage of
Becca's documentary why doesn't she sent
her mom any of it yeah maybe she doesn't
want anybody to see it until she's done
with it but it seems like if she wants
more answers she'd try and show her mom
some of this movie Stacey doesn't
immediately leave and contact the
authorities to tell them that the crazy
people who are missing are living in the
house of the nice elderly couple who are
also missing also a girl who is certain
these people killed the actual
grandparents willingly walks behind the
house and apparently she is murdered
without the kids even hearing it and
Hailey's kids are curious enough that
I'm shocked it and follow them with a
camera somehow I know a story it's about
water is it my channel I'm trying to
remind us that lady in the water
happened
these creatures spit into the water
their spit can make you sleep creatures
from another planet have many people at
the bottom of the pond they are going to
take them back to their planet of
sinmorfitellia one day Becca is not
acting like this is the weirdest fucking
thing she's ever hurt why are you doing
this is how children play okay method
acting conveniently nor in conveniently
due to how much time it took them the
kids figuring out a way to get the dry
batter off the webcam just in time for
the movie's finale why they couldn't do
it earlier it's beyond our comprehension
Becca Tyler babies a sane mother would
have asked who the hell are those people
two minutes ago police department also
why call the hick police directly her
children have basically been kidnapped
call 911 they could send a wide array of
first responders to the house ah
I think fake grandpa just got cooked up
could you clean the oven for me Becca
since Becca clean that oven two days ago
and she just found out these aren't her
grandparents I feel like she has a
pretty good excuse to say no nothing
comes of this yet we are still bothering
with it this is a small girl but that
oven door can really hold some weight
they just don't make them like they used
to bizarro Nana and pop-pop murdered
Stacy in the middle of the day
hung her corpse from a tree but the kids
don't see it until right now see he's
using strategy Milton Bradley approved
strategy this game was made by Hasbro
pop pop sometimes that guy can be a
teenage girl also it was her desire to
be right really so strong that she'd
contradict an insane murderer right to
his face I choose to believe she
actually got Yahtzee also scaring with
your mouth open and that's why you never
volunteer at a mental institution also I
find it really hard to believe that she
couldn't smell decomposing bodies it
doesn't matter how cold it is down there
you would smell something
wasn't that a perfect week I promised
her what they well they had to murder
someone else and they didn't have cell
service so he was fine when does Tyler
get hit in the head and why didn't we
get to see it I would have enjoyed that
pop-pop is playing with fire now
free-balling with fecal incontinence I
never liked you
understandable he heard the rabbit
knowing where Nana Claire is at all time
seems like a must yeah here we are
getting more establishing shots of the
room you a problem with Jerome's don't
you I don't think anyone needs to have a
problem with germs to find this
disgusting Zinaida gonna turn into a
butterfly just push her off the bed
sheet for sure break a hip
movie steals the deus ex machina from
tangled putting your victims in a
suitcase or hanging them from trees old
news cannibalism is the new thing for
Nana a past sports failure is overcome
and comes in handy at the final moment
to stop the bad guy also the exact same
thing happened to the Joaquin Phoenix
character in science this is a very
specific motif I think M night Shyamalan
is trying to exorcise some pretty
hardcore childhood demons someone check
his little league records her camera can
really withstand that beating and still
record I want to find this garbage bin
with magic cameras in it
I hit my mother and then my dad hit me
that's it that's the incident that made
her hate her parents for 15 years she
started it they reached out to me
soon after I refused to take their calls
for 15 years incredible slaty is a real
piece of work
hope her kids know never to fight with
mom or she'll cut them off until they
die don't hold on to anger Beck what a
false equivalence a teen girl who hates
her father for abandoning their family
is a totally different thing from a teen
girl and then a grown woman in her 30s
who hates her parents for telling her
she has a boyfriend who by the way they
were totally right about also I'd be
less concerned about Becca and her
brother holding on to anger at their
father than I would be about them having
just killed two people just because it's
self-defense doesn't mean
won't need a boatload of therapy reading
movie ends with more thirteen-year-old
white boy rap just in case you were
jonesing after the other two times also
after an ordeal like this wouldn't
Becca's documentary be like a huge hit
movie when they'd be famous or is this
one of those diamond doesn't fake
grandparents who escaped from a mental
institution imposed to someone's real
grandparents type of stories
I'm a problem with journalists don't you
tickets please tickets wait Josh Josh is
that you down there
Oh Kelly Clarkson I never liked you I
don't like you either
tell us something we don't know William
I forgot to tell you your mom called she
says you gotta call home immediately
and she says to tell you I know what's
going on
Oh